welcome back to PJ train Design This is
PJ jewelry care design it's not hard at
all if you know the correct way to build
the model today I'm going to show you
just three four simple command to make
this ring are you ready let's get
started
before we get started there's a few
things we need to think about when we do
any of the design like this first of all
this is more like right at this spot
this is more like a half of the channel
set so this Stone will need to cut in
into the metal here in order to hold the
stone on that side now the other side is
actually holding on the prong the second
thing is you do not want to have the
wall Too Tall otherwise the stone will
get really dark and make sure the
coolant of the stone is not sticking out
from the bottom of the ring shank and so
for this ring and that will be more
comfortable to wear it alright that's
starting from the scratch we are going
to starting a ring from the front view
with the circle command for the diameter
I want it to be 16 and for you you can
use any size and then I'm going to bring
in a stone for whatever size that you're
going to use and you can download the
song in the description below and I'm
just gonna move the stuff on the side
and it's not set yeah we can we can
change it later if you want to the stone
doesn't have to be too tall too low you
just need to be away from The Ring rail
for the stone let's use the arc command
and snapping into the vertex and we're
gonna have something similar like this
the size will be changing so if that
doesn't fit that's okay the second
things we wanted to do is to draw a line
roughly about
like this right instead of drawing the
curve I like to use the blank command
we're going to use a blank curve I'm
gonna blend in between here and here and
then to get this one all right since
this is symmetrical I'm just going to
mirror to the other side
like this and join those three together
I usually like to do is to edit those oh
and by the way the front view you see
this is snapping like that so we need to
make sure it's flat so let's go ahead to
project to C plane on my top view and we
want to delete the input so you'll be
flattened to the construction plane all
right so that's that first of all I
would like to rebuild this guy to be a
odd number so it was a 13 point so if we
stay with the 13 point you see like how
pointy that is so maybe I want to do the
17 point so I will get something like
this and then this is a time you can
start editing the shape to making into
the shape that you like and I think the
shape like this it might be okay so the
next things I wanted to do is draw a
straight line make sure it's from the
quadrant here and go like this and draw
another straight line go like this this
is is actually going to be the ring
shank the shape of my ring so I'm going
to use a trim command to trim the one in
the middle here here and like that okay
so this curve right here so let me go
ahead to join this one all right so this
is the curve uh it's actually our ring
shank now this curve right here you need
to follow this curve on the top portion
here so I'm going to coming into my
perspective and showing you with the
command for curve from 2 view so this
Curve will be follow this shape right
here and you're going to see this one
let me turn it into the green color here
we can use our original curve and to
trim off
this guy right here
this guy right here all right so we just
need the top portion there all right and
you can rebuild this guy if you want to
let's give it a try by creating the
shape first so first shape I wanted to
do is to do the um profile and for this
profile I want the color for about this
high and for about
this why it doesn't have to be like
really rounded just a little bit radius
on the age and you just need a stone
cutting a little bit and just need to
make sure that the circle that we have
originally let me draw you again
with the diameter we have the the stone
doesn't get close in there all right and
then if that is the case you can make
this a bit longer if you want to and
just move it down a little bit maybe
that'll look prettier okay and the on
the other side we will have two profile
here and since they are going to be the
same I'm going to draw just the first
one again using the colony corner on my
rectangle I'm going to draw something
look like this okay and let's go ahead
to moving this guy to this point and
making a copy from this end to this end
okay now let's go ahead to sweep it and
see how you look let's go sweep one you
got this one you go from here turning to
here coming back to here and then this
is the look I also want to record a
history just in case if I wanted to
change it all right you can see that the
button is cutting inside of it that's
okay we can trim it out later on but if
you don't like to be cutting it you can
make them a bit shorter and since you
record a history so everything should be
changed with you so that way we don't
cut it like way too much there you can
continue to edit until you find the
shape that you like right or you can
make it continue to make it shorter
going up a little bit taller so we can
trim in that later okay so that is that
now the second thing we wanted to do is
we want this guy and this guy now let me
join them together and we want to sweep
again from this end all of way to this
end right I actually don't want to have
a closed curve so let's join this way
and see how it goes so we wanted to do
the sweep one rail and this is going to
be our rail this is going to be the
cross section and let's see what
happened and you can see it's coming out
from this side right and it's it's not
what we want we actually wanted them to
go in so this is the point that you will
need to rebuild this one to be degree
three and I wanted to have last point
maybe 12 point should be enough and as
soon as you don't sacrifice here I see
the deviation right there so maybe we
need to bump up for 16 and then click ok
so now what we want to do is coming into
my top view I wanted this going inside
right so let me align them first
and now the top view of my front view
and then I wanted to go is to rotate it
this in a little bit something like this
all right so it will touch you let's
give it a try we wanted to
um sweep one rail and gonna pick up this
curve and you want to record a history
it's just in case we can change it all
right so apparently this is not coming
enough so since we recorded history we
can pick up this curve and we can pick
up the point that we want them to come
back a little bit more so maybe all
those points in my front view and I want
to rotate it a little bit more alright
so if that looked right to you we are
going to pick up this curve again
and using the sweep one rail and do on
the other side
all right so for the bottom of the stone
we need to have on the bezel so let's go
ahead to create a cylinder and simply
snapping into the vertex and I wanted
the cylinder is smaller than my stone
otherwise you're going to see the stone
the metal stick it out of the stone and
it doesn't look good all right so that
is our under bezel actually is Too Tall
so that's one descale it down and bring
it down a little bit we also need a
prong so I simply just going to draw a
straight line about like this and at
this one I'm going to pipe it
for the roughly the size like this all
right and if if it's too tall because
we're adding the cap you can always 1D
scale it down and so that will be our
ring today I hope you enjoyed the video
I have a lot more for you today if you
wanted to be a jewelry cat designer I
wanted to show you the three most
important things to boost your jury care
design skill this is a completely free
webinar and the link is in the
description below check it out and let
me know how you like it thank you for
watching and I will see you next
[Music]
thank you